[Musique]
aide à maintenir et soutenir la santé
cardiovasculaire soulage les douleurs
articulaires aide à contribuer aux
fonctions cérébrales soutien l'equilibre
de l'humeur aide à améliorer les
fonctions de la mémoire
ce ne sont que quelques-uns des
attributs donner aux suppléments
d'oméga-3 que l'on peut se procurer en
vente libre
docteur en nutrition karine grave elle
enseigne au département de nutrition de
la faculté de médecine de l'université
de montréal
oui attrayant mais oui il ya plein de
d'allégations pousser les allégations
c'est démontré en que ce soit pour les
suppléments ou les animaux mais ça fait
vendre c'est attirant on a l'impression
que ça va fonctionner les fabricants
peuvent faire de tels énoncés pourvu
qu'ils respectent les directives de
santé canada qui déterminent ce qui peut
ou ne peut pas être dit et les
suppléments se présente sous toutes les
formes
à croquer en huile en gélules déclinée
en différentes compositions pour hommes
femmes et enfants ils sont faits d'huile
de poisson de l'est d'algues de krill et
même de loup marin
leurs prix sont plutôt élevés et les
affirmations vantant leurs vertus sont
nombreuses
on voit qu'il ya plein de defoe a ajouté
on s'adresse à des consommateurs
spécifique donc été chacun peut trouver
le son supplément idéal
les oméga 3 sont des acides gras
contenus dans certains aliments et une
variété de produits qui en sont enrichis
leur consommation est nécessaire pour
maintenir une bonne santé
ils proviennent soit des végétaux ou du
monde marin on assez gras oméga-3
renoncer grand qu'on dit est essentielle
parce que notre corps est pas capable de
synthétiser donc il doit obligatoirement
provenir des aliments le cardiologue
christophe eux la bosse est aussi
épidémiologistes
il a scruté à la loupe toutes les
récentes études sur les effets des oméga
3 il y avait quand même
initialement beaucoup d'enthousiasmé aux
hommes aux oméga toi parce qu'on
commençait en regardant les études
observationnelles donc les études roues
on voit que les patients les personnes
qui viennent des populations on mange
beaucoup de poissons avaient en général
moins de maladies cardiovasculaires que
lé population qui venaient des pays où
ils mangent moins de poissons 1,3 g
d'oméga 3 par jour pour les femmes et
1,6 pour les hommes est considéré comme
un apport suffisant
cette quantité se trouve généralement
dans notre alimentation de tous les
jours car c'est dans les aliments et
qu'il ya vraiment quelque chose
d'intéressant qui est démontré c'est ça
mais là on a voulu s'appuyer sur 100 m
dans des gélules en haîti capsule qui on
aurait pu vraiment à se préoccuper de ce
qu'on mange on va s'assurer d'avoir tout
ce qu'il faut ça va être plus simple de
prendre nous sommes il ya trois sous
forme de supplément et si les
suppléments qui sont problématiques que
dans les études où on voit pas d'effet
ou moins d'effet que prévu
en effet l'analyse de 91 étude récente
portant sur près de 225 mille patients
révèle que la prise de suppléments
d'oméga-3 n'est pas efficace pour
prévenir les maladies cardiovasculaires
chez les personnes qui n'ont pas
d'antécédent quelqu'un qui est en bonne
santé et n'a pas de maladie n'a jamais
fait un acv allait prendre un supplément
d'oméga toi c'est pas vraiment
recommandé ça se trouve vraiment pas
dans la majorité des lignes directrices
qui existe et le bénéfice est
probablement soit mini ou probablement
même 0 par contre en prévention
secondaire soit pour protéger ceux et
celles qui ont des jeunes maladies
cardiovasculaires ou qui doivent réduire
les triglycérides sanguins
les études démontrent certains bénéfices
à prendre des oméga-3 prescrit par un
médecin
[Musique]
voir nos un petit de ville avant d'aller
voir du côté des suppléments et ses
suppléments représente un marché de près
de 200 millions de dollars au canada
voici ce que disent les plus récentes
études en ce qui a trait à leurs effets
sur la santé santé cardiovasculaire les
suppléments d'oméga-3 on peut le dire
santé articulaires en général quand on
regarde les études on voit très peu de
bénéfices et probablement pas quelque
chose qu'on recommande la santé
cognitive
plusieurs études ont été faits sur ce
point en terme de prévention de démence
dans sa grille des choses comme ça on va
pas vraiment de pression c'est pas
quelque chose qu'on utilise de façon
quotidienne c'est pas quelque chose
qu'on recommande aux gens et l'elysée et
la preuve est vraiment pas là on voit
beaucoup d'allégations que s'arrête le
sucre sous même la somme au moment de la
grossesse qu'est-ce que sinon eh oui
l'idée pour la femme enceinte c'est que
si on donne les oméga-3 ça va aider avec
le développement du cerveau du bébé
c'est une idée intéressante mais un
crêpe de preuves pour le supporter pour
les enfants ça vous rappelle ou pas ils
ont déjà fait des études pour les
enfants pour le pph et honnêtement la
nage étaient des preuves ne montre
aucune bénéfices alors même pour les
enfants ça semble pas les suppléments
d'oméga-3 et si les performances
sportives
ça c'est peut-être quelque chose qui
serait intéressant pour les athlètes qui
sont en formation pour les olympiques où
quelque chose mais pour la population
générale
je penserai pas qu'il y aura un grand
des frais plus importante de juste sorti
dehors les marchés de façon quotidienne
ça va faire plus de bien
probablement l'inflammation peut-elle
être contrôlés avec des suppléments
d'oméga 3 et 7 cramé à tracer des
molécules anti inflammatoire ça c'est
fait mais en même temps
toujours la question de se demander
est-ce que c'est justifié de prendre un
supplément tc quoi l'ensemble de nos
habitudes de vie bien qu'il soit
pertinent d'augmenter notre consommation
d'oméga 3 il est toujours préférable de
choisir les aliments au supplément
la solution se trouve donc dans ce que
l'on met dans notre assiette comtal des
oméga-3 du point-g alimentaire il faut
comprendre que pour la majorité de
pâques du population on parle de
remplacer de la viande par les poissons
alors changez notre alimentation c'est
peut-être mieux que de prendre un
supplément parce que on peut non
seulement manger les bonnes choses comme
les oméga 3 du poisson mais on va aussi
éliminer une mauvaise chose qui saute
qui peuvent nuire à notre santé
c'est important de mesurer l'effet de
l'aliment c'est sur la santé peut juste
de considérer les nutriments qui est
dans pi extrapoler les effets sur la
santé
donc on peut avoir des surprises mais je
pense que c'est un peu ce qui est arrivé
avec les suppléments d'oméga-3 donc on
avait extrapoler un petit peu trop vite
les effets sur la santé cardiovasculaire
les suppléments les effets sont par
contre bien réelle sur les ressources
marines car comme le souligne
l'environnementaliste paul greenberg
l'industrie qui s'est érigé autour de
l'extraction des huiles de poisson
consomme 10 millions de tonnes de la
faune marine chaque année autant de
ressources qui ne met pas plus de
protéines dans notre assiette